he called up he said I want you to read
something and I went over and read Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood sitting there
in his in his Hollywood Lair he just
loves the history of everything in
Hollywood and I looked at him I said I
don't know if there's anybody left alive
who can appreciate this as much as me
and he said I know as he wrote in this
dedication in the book it was a lot of
drawn from some conversations that we'd
had about my relationship with my stun
and and one in particular there was a
relationship my dad had with a stuntman
irn Neil a lot of true things there and
those shows that I done my dad had done
and stuff that Quenton gets a kick out
of just what he's able to do take things
and turn them on her head and then as
the night we you know had couple drinks
and night went on I think DiCaprio came
over that night and maybe Brad Pit and
probably three four o'clock in the
morning all right good night I got to go
on the way out he says oh yeah and I
want you to play Randy I said Randy
who's Randy he said the stun coordinator
I said I I never even saw okay I'll be
there for Randy he's something else